okay sure the two kinds are well you
think about when you turn around there's
two ways to turn around okay if the sign
changes before and after okay you can
have think about this the sign of D Y or
Y or DX
okay if he goes positive and then 0 and
then negative okay what would that mean
it would mean it's going up and then
it's going horizontal and then it goes
down okay so we would call this maximum
okay okay so later on after this topic
after you exam actually we will talk
about finding max mean you know maximum
time for this me to vouch for that
maximum area maximum temperature
whatever okay so this is a maximum so
this is the kind of pattern we're
looking for but of course you can have
the reverse pattern right I should do it
over on the side if you've got a
different kind of pattern right if it
goes negative and zero and they're
positive well it's drew beautiful
platinum decreasing then horizontal then
increasing this is what a maximum it's a
minimum okay that's an M that's totally
distance sorry
my writing is night so maximum 25
minimum table okay ah now I keep on
getting down right there's much as
máximos and/or maxima and minima is also
I want to distinguish between as local
okay or relative as opposed to global
sorry
or absolute now what it was this me okay
I could say to you now cause you're snow
is that tallest mountain full stop okay
now that would be almost true right well
it would be true in a certain locality
right namely Australia right of course
it's not it's not true in the whole
world actually cause your skirt hardly
qualifies the corner Melton it's more
like a large hill right so when you know
seriously so when you think about
everywhere okay even though it might be
the highest place nearby okay if you
think about everywhere the entire world
globally it's not the highest okay so I
can also think of this in terms of you
know for instance either either I am
assuming that it Justin or Daniel Daniel
is the tallest person or relative to
everyone else in this class right yeah
yeah I don't know I never see you
standing up tall next Vuitton so anyway
to the tallest person in this class
right he's taught this relative to us
okay but there might be someone who's
actually I is this somewhat taller than
you you have the brain yeah Kevin so
while we're talking about let me try to
illustrate it for you okay let's have a
look at a function let's say I just
gotta make
so this is a cubic function yes now have
a look at it
there are two stationary points and they
also happen to both be turning points
number one number two okay so if I were
to label these right I would say well
look this one over here it goes positive
zero negative for my ingredients right
so this is a max max anyway okay this
one of course is the opposite behavior
so it's a minimal okay but more than
that both of these are what we call
relative because you can look at the
graph and see there are obviously points
that are higher than this maximum like
you know any point over here and there
are obviously points that are lower than
this minimum any points over here okay
so these are their relative Max and min
but not the absolute maximum now I've
given you both of these sets of words
okay because they'll appear in different
textbooks that cannot be here we prefer
these relative and absolute okay because
this is a meant to geographical for the
master carpets so together I would
prefer these but when you see these
that's what they really mean okay